Well, if it isn't
the White fucking Wolf
and the big fucking mouth.
Put your weapons down.
Numpty arseholes.
This is an old friend.
Fucking…
Yarpen is the leader
of a group of mercenary dwarves.
Dwarves are one of
the elder races on the Continent.
There's five of us.
Myself, we have two brothers,
Paulie and Regan Dahlberg,
Xavier Moran,
and Yannick Brass.
This weapon in particular
is called a martel.
It's just to show
you don't mess with dwarves,
or if you do,
that's what's gonna happen.
It has a flat edge on this side
and the other side
has mortar spikes.
I think that's Yarpen to a T.
They have a sense of humor
about them
because they've
been through so much.
In order to get by,
you gotta have a good laugh.
Be happy to have you
as our sixth,
even if you do smell like shite.
Witchers and dwarves,
throughout all of the time
on the Continent,
have been looked at
as being inferior.
They come for the elves.
They'll come for the dwarves.
And sooner or later,
they will come for everyone.